Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank,"
Katrina Lake,
the founder of billion‐dollar
online fashion company
Stitch Fix
joins the Tank.
I had the exact
same epiphany.
What you guys have done
is amazing.
High five!
I love this business.
Yes, you can tell,
and it's infectious.
Yeah!
Look, I see two cockroaches
with glasses on.
You know, we think this is
a really fair offer.
Katrina, they've said no to you
seven times in different ways.
Don't you want me?
Baby?
[ Laughter ]
Cuban: You got to decide
right now.
I don't want to even deal
with all these meatheads.
Ohh!
♪♪
Narrator: First in the Tank
is a reinvention of a product
that hasn't been innovated
in over 100 years.
♪♪
‐Hi, Sharks, I'm Lindsay.
‐And I'm Asher.
And our company
is Bite Toothpaste Bits.
We're asking for $325,000
for 5% of our company.
Wow.
People first used to brush
their teeth with this ‐‐
Ox hooves and bones.
Mmm! And then in the 1800s,
we started using this ‐‐
‐Eggshells and soap.
‐A little better.
And then, in 1886, there was
a major innovation ‐‐
the first toothpaste tube
was invented.
And after 150 years, toothpaste
hasn't really changed.
And why?
Toothpaste sucks.
Sharks, we are swimming
in plastic.
About 1 billion
plastic toothpaste tubes
end up in our landfills and
our oceans every single year,
and even though people care more
about what they're putting
in their bodies now, most
toothpastes are still filled
with things like artificial
flavors and preservatives.
And that's not good because
we swallow 5% to 7%
of our toothpaste every single
time we brush our teeth,
or 1.4 gallons over the course
of your lifetime.
Bite Toothpaste Bits
are dry tablets
that are not only good
for your teeth,
they're good for our bodies
and the planet.
And our bits come in glass jars
that are fully recyclable,
but they're meant
to be kept and refilled
with our compostable
refill packets.
Meaning no more plastic
toothpaste tubes in landfills.
It's as easy as bite,
brush, repeat.
Big paste is on a race
to the bottom.
And they've gotten away
with gunking up our bodies
and our planet
for far too long.
So, Sharks...
Who's ready to take a bite
out of big paste with us?
How does it work?
You all have jars
in front of you.
You just pop a bit
in your mouth, you bite down,
and you start brushing
with a wet toothbrush,
and it's gonna foam
up like magic.
There you go! There you go,
there you go, there you go.
I've brushed before.
So, our tablets...
[ Laughs ]
...they're flavored with
natural mint peppermint oil.
‐[ Gurgling ]
‐[ Laughs ]
Lori, your face
is priceless.
[ Laughs ]
So, is the goal here because
the toothpaste
isn't as healthy for me
as your product,
or are you just trying to get
rid of the plastic?
Well, it's two‐fold.
So, when I created this,
I was traveling
full time for work,
and I went through those
little toothpaste tubes,
and I was like,
"This is so wasteful."
So I started looking
into alternatives,
and that's when I learned
about all
of the really nasty chemicals
that's in most toothpastes,
and I was like, "I don't want
those in my body."
So I started looking into
how I can make my own.
I'm not a dentist,
and I'm not a chemist,
so I made friends with them.
‐[ Laughs ]
I talked to every dentist
and every dental hygienist
I possibly could, I took
online chemistry classes,
and I tried almost
100 different ingredients,
putting together our formula
that we use in our tablets.
And she was hand‐cranking these
in our living room.
‐[ Chuckles ] Yeah.
‐Seriously?
Are you married?
Yeah, well, we've been dating
for six years.
Want me to marry you now?
[ Laughs ]
‐You know, I do that.
‐I heard you're ordained.
Yeah, it's true.
'Cause I'm just wondering,
six years, like,
let's get going here.
‐Yeah, exactly.
‐We got companies to build.
Lake: So, Lindsay,
so this was me.
So, I travel a ton, I had the
exact same epiphany of just,
like, "What are all these
chemicals in the toothpaste?"
I went down this rabbit hole.
I don't think I found you guys,
but I found
a tablet‐based toothpaste,
and the dentist told me,
"Don't use that,
it doesn't have fluoride,
and you need fluoride."
‐Right.
‐Ohh.
We're actually in development
with a fluoride line.
We are in the middle of testing
right now,
and we will be seeking
ADA approval,
and we will be the only
fluorinated tablet
on the market in the U. S.
I wanted to speak
to how it tastes ‐‐
Lindsay, I just learned
from Katrina here
that there's competition.
There's lots of other people
doing this, right?
McCormick: There's a few
on the market.
The form of toothpaste
in a tablet is not new.
What is new about ours is
that it comes in glass bottles,
compostable refill packets,
and we're 100% palm oil free.
Lindsay,
do you guys have sales?
Uh, we're on our way
to $1.3 million.
‐Oh, that's good.
‐Wow.
‐Boom goes the dynamite!
‐In 10 months.
‐Yes.
‐Wow.
So, when I came up with it,
I figured no one would buy it,
but I knew I wanted it,
and that would be great,
and that's enough.
So, I built this site
on Shopify,
and then a popular women's
magazine was like,
"We would like to, you know,
showcase this."
So, we took ‐‐
It was like an iPhone video,
like, you know,
me brushing my teeth.
Within a day,
it was like 2 million views.
‐That's amazing.
‐Have you taken any money?
‐Zero dollars raised.
‐And no debt.
Yeah.
What do you sell it for?
What does it cost you?
Uh, the 1‐ounce bottle,
which is our 1‐month,
that costs $12
plus shipping.
Um, for the 4‐month, that's $30,
shipping is included.
That is a subscription.
What's your cost on this?
Our cost on that, shipped,
is about $3.50.
‐Wow!
‐Yeah.
‐Wow.
‐All right, guys, look,
all of the Sharks
here over a decade...
Yeah.
...have learned that
when they get a hit
that is a non‐proprietary
consumer good...
Right.
...they get
knocked off el pronto
by many, many, many knock‐offs.
‐So, we already had ‐‐
I think something's that's
also pretty extraordinary,
it's our customers.
They are very vocal.
So, my first version of these
had a small amount of palm oil,
and our customers
were like,
"Hey, you have palm oil
in your formula.
What is this?"
And I was like,
"Oh, wow, you're right.
Palm oil is responsible
for the devastation
of the rainforests
in Indonesia
and the orangutan population,
and that doesn't
align with our values."
So, we completely reformulated
our entire line
within four months.
Once we did that, our sales
doubled that month,
and they've continued
to climb.
That's great, you're listening
to your customers.
‐You're just online?
‐Yes.
You're 100% online?
We are entirely
direct‐to‐consumer right now.
How many subscribers do you
have? What's your churn?
Yeah, so we have just
under 10,000 subscribers.
That's great.
You know your customer
acquisition cost now?
Yeah, our customer acquisition
cost, blended, is about $4.50,
and our AOV is close to $27.
‐That's great.
‐That's nice.
[ Chuckles ]
Can you keep this run up
with these phenomenal
customer acquisition margins?
Because they're great.
What you've done is amazing.
When there's nothing
proprietary,
and when you get a full‐fledged
binge of knock‐offs,
I think your customer
acquisition goes up
and your margins go down,
and then all of a sudden,
it's a real cat fight.
Consumers are becoming
incredibly conscious,
and they're looking
for products
that are truly trying
to make a difference.
But it's our base that is
fanatical about us
that will help us
continue to grow ‐‐
Look, I can't think
of a more competitive shelf.
It's more competitive than
pretty well anything else
in terms of just linear foot,
gross margin,
the fighting it out,
all that stuff.
And especially
with that backdrop,
I mean, what you guys have done
is amazing.
And doing this
all bootstrapped
and in this short period
of time,
and the product is awesome,
and the packaging is great,
and the brand is great.
But I think this is
a really crowded space
and potentially getting
even more crowded.
I wish you guys had
fluoride in the formulation.
So, with that, I'm out.
‐Thank you.
I guess I'm sitting here,
I'm thinking,
"How can ‐‐ How can ‐‐"
You're only offering me 5%
for $325,000.
Like, where do I fit?
Maybe this isn't a business
that needs funding right now.
We don't want dumb money.
We've had institutional
investors approach us.
We look at all of you guys
that are up here,
and we want a Shark.
Look, not in a million years
would I do it for 5%.
I'm out.
I'd do the $325,000 for 20%.
$325,000 for 20%.
Thank you for your offer,
first of all.
Yeah.
I'll tell my reasons why,
listen.
I'm just telling you right now,
what I look at
is risk versus reward,
and I think the margins
a year from now will be
significantly less,
and your customer acquisition
costs will be higher, too.
You know,
using the "Shark Tank" platform
in a consumer product like this
is fantastic,
but it doesn't make you
impervious to competition.
It just brings in
a lot of knock‐offs.
That's my offer.
I'll give you $325,000 for 20%.
Well, listen, I usually find
that the most successful people
have the strongest principles.
They believe in something
so much that it drives them,
and clearly you have that.
But I'm really kind of
on the fence about this.
I tend to follow my gut, and
I think here, I'm gonna go out.
Thank you.
Mark?
Guys, I love it when there's
a stodgy old industry,
and somebody walks in and says,
"Let's just turn this
upside down."
Are you guys selling
on Amazon at all?
Hunt: We experimented with it,
and we took it off.
Because?
Because we just
wanted to focus on building
our relationships with our
customers direct to consumer.
But that's where your
knock‐offs can take root.
Yes, we would definitely
consider going back on Amazon.
When you run
with the elephants,
there's the quick
and the dead, right?
Right. We've stayed away from
Amazon because of that.
However, our customers are
looking for us on Amazon.
On Amazon, exactly.
And we should be there
for them.
So, guys,
I'll make you an offer.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Asher and Lindsay are seeking
$325,000
for 5% of their toothpaste
tablet company, Bite.
Kevin has offered $325,000
for 20% of the company,
but Mark is also interested.
So, I'll give you the 325K,
but I need 15%.
♪♪
Wow, you're
undercutting Kevin.
Uh, what would you think about
doing $325,000 at the 5%,
and then we give you
an additional 2% as an adviser?
2%?
Guys, look, if I'm ‐‐
If you really want me to work,
if you really want me to take
all our Amazon expertise
and get you specialty
Prime locations,
into their different programs
for sustainable products,
7%, even with 5 plus 2, you
know, is not gonna get it done.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Hmm.
So, would you have any
flexibility on how much equity
you're willing to part with
today?
'Cause, I mean,
we're quite far apart.
Oh, and by the way,
Kevin had an offer on the table
20 minutes ago.
Yeah, I'm not going
to change my offer.
I've been here before.
There's a fair amount
of work ahead
and a lot of competition coming.
Yeah.
But I'm not coming
down from 20%.
So, you should focus on Mark
here and see if you can get him.
Mark's giving you
a good offer.
Yeah, um, that's our ‐‐
Lindsay, you have something
really rare
that very few people come in
here with these kind of sales.
You own 100% of the company.
‐Yeah.
There's no
shareholder advisers.
I know, so that's
why this is a big deal.
‐And it should be a big deal.
‐That's why I'm like, "Man,
Mark, I want to work with you,
but this is a lot."
Herjavec: But it also means
you have the flexibility.
He's at 15%, you're at 7%.
So 15%, okay.
♪♪
What have you decided?
We really, really appreciate
the offer, Mark.
We just can't do that
to our valuation.
‐Understand completely, guys.
‐It's Mark Cuban.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐I know, and you're such a G!
You don't have to explain.
I respect you guys,
appreciate it.
I'll be a customer,
and I wish you the best.
Well, hang on!
Kevin is left.
Oh, Kevin, I'm sorry.
[ Laughs ]
Well, I'm sorry.
It all comes down
to Mr. Wonderful.
Thank you very much
for your offer.
Now that Mark's out of it,
this gives me more leverage.
I'll do it for 25%.
[ Laughter ]
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Thank you.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Thank you, thank you.
Thank you guys so much.
‐Thank you.
♪♪
We wanted to work with Mark
or Kevin or really any of them,
but to go so far away
from what we're asking for,
we just couldn't ‐‐
couldn't do it.
Yeah.
It is shocking
when someone says no to me.
When was the last time
that even happened?
‐That was a good offer!
‐That happens all the time.
Are you okay?
Do you need a hug?
Mark, why'd they walk away
from that?
They're rolling right now.
When your business is going
like this,
and you haven't hit
the real adversity yet,
then you don't know.
When things are good, you think
they'll be good forever.
Right. Everybody's a genius
in a bull market.
♪♪
I was born and raised
in San Francisco.
My mom is an immigrant
from Japan,
and my dad is from Minnesota,
so I grew up in a very vibrant,
bilingual,
bicultural household.
Growing up, I always thought
I wanted to be a doctor.
I went to Stanford,
I was pre‐med,
but ultimately decided that
wasn't for me.
After college, I got a job
at a consulting firm
working in e‐commerce.
I really fell in love
with retail,
and I think in particular,
apparel retail.
I felt like there
was no technology
that really was being applied
to help make the category
better.
At Stitch Fix, we take this idea
of personal styling,
and we make it
accessible to all.
We get to know our clients
through a style profile
which you can fill out online.
Based on that, our stylists
are able to get to know you
and send you products
specifically curated
just for you to try on
in the comfort of your home.
Simply keep what you want,
send back what you don't want,
and get
this great personal experience
for the whole household.
Combining data science
and styling
was really not something that
people had done before.
Fundraising was really
difficult.
Over 50 venture investors said
no to me.
Being a female business leader
in Silicon Valley,
you don't always feel like
your voice is heard.
It's really male‐dominated.
I wasn't always obvious,
where people thought, "Oh, yes,
of course she's gonna be
a public company CEO someday."
In early 2011,
we got our first commitment
from a venture investor,
Steve Anderson,
and that was really when we were
off to the races.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The stock has opened.
This crowd is excited.
You can see Katrina Lake
over there with her crew.
Lake: In 2017,
we took the company public.
At the time, I was the youngest
female founder/CEO
to take a company public ever.
I was up there with my family
and my son,
who was one at the time,
and I think it was really
a symbol of what's possible
being a parent and being able to
prioritize parenthood
and your business
at the same time.
Stitch Fix today is a company
with over $1 billion in sales.
We have over 3 million clients
across the whole country,
and we have
over 6,000 employees.
I've watched "Shark Tank"
for years,
and I love that it showcases
all kinds of entrepreneurs.
It's such an important part
of helping people to see
that entrepreneurship is not
available to only a select few.
What I love about
entrepreneurship
is the optimism.
You're believing in something
that lots of people
don't believe in,
and you are taking a point
of view
that's not a common
point of view,
and that optimism is super
infectious, really energizing.
It's an environment
I love being in.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is an affordable solution
for baby gear.
♪♪
‐Ohh!
‐[ Laughs ]
Oh! [ Laughs ]
Hi, Sharks, I'm Joe Maier,
and this is my mom, Fran Maier.
We're from San Francisco,
California,
and we're seeking $500,000 for
5% equity in our business...
‐Oh, wow!
‐BabyQuip!
Sharks, everyone knows that
when you travel with kids,
the amount of baggage you have
to lug around can be insane.
Oh.
You need a pack mule just to
carry this crazy amount of gear.
But the problem is
a pack mule
is pretty hard to come by
nowadays.
So, what happens?
The parent
becomes the pack mule.
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
Joe:
Look at this poor dad.
Why can't traveling
with kids be easier?
Fran:
Well, now, you can have all this
delivered straight to your door!
♪♪
Introducing BabyQuip.
Our online rental platform
connects traveling families
to our independent
local providers
to supply all
of your baby gear needs.
Joe: We offer everything from
full‐size cribs, car seats,
high chairs, toy boxes,
and more.
You name it, we got it.
Simply log onto
our website,
enter your destination
and travel dates...
Choose one of our local
providers to rent from.
From there, simply select
any of our clean, safe...
[ Laughter ]
...and insured baby gear.
And it's literally
as easy as that.
Once you arrive
at your destination,
our providers will deliver your
equipment right to your door.
With BabyQuip, we say
leave that baggage behind.
So, Sharks, it's time
to pack up this mule
and get him out of here.
[ Laughter ]
So, Fran, I have
13‐month‐old twins.
Oh, I know!
That's great.
It is ‐‐ It is
an adventure to travel.
Exactly.
What does it cost on average?
Like, how much
is a double stroller?
Probably $15 to $20 a day
depending on the market.
So, you've got to ship it
to wherever the location is?
No. Our secret sauce,
we have 500 providers.
If I'm the provider,
am I saying,
"I'm gonna rent that
out for $30,"
or are you setting
the price?
Our providers set
their own prices.
The providers
pick their own pricing?
‐So it's not a set menu?
‐No, no, no.
We are a marketplace
for baby gear rentals.
I've never heard of this.
Like, every time I go ‐‐
Right. That's why
we need you!
What do you take
from the transaction?
We take 24%.
‐24%?
‐Greiner: Wow.
Yipee‐yi‐yo‐ki‐yay.
That's really healthy.
This is so we can build
a business that will scale,
that will grow,
and we put more than one
provider in every market.
Okay, so,
let's go right into sales.
Now that I'm going 24%,
which I like.
Mr. Wonderful likes that.
‐Good.
We started this business
in the middle of 2016.
Since then, we've done
$3.7 million in gross revenue.
‐Wow.
‐That's top line.
‐What's your percentage?
‐We keep about 24% of that.
Not quite a million
on the $3.7 million.
What about investors?
Um, so we've raised
$2.4 million to date
on a valuation of $8 million.
‐Oh.
‐What?
‐Wow.
What do you need
the money for?
[ Chuckles ]
We need the money
to continue our growth,
grow awareness.
This last bunch of money
will get us to profitability
next year.
And tell us about you.
Tell us about your background.
So, I'm a serial
entrepreneur.
My first startup was Match.
‐Match? Wow.
‐Match.com?
Match.com!
‐Online dating.
‐Come on! High five.
‐All right, thank you.
‐Wow.
Congratulations.
‐Uh, hey, guess what ‐‐
‐What?
We sold it for way too little,
way too early.
Cuban:
What did you sell it for?
Less than $8 million.
And it's a long
story short ‐‐
You sold Match for less than $8?
It's a long story.
‐Hey, listen, a lesson learned.
‐It was pre‐Internet, though.
You sold it kind of like
pre‐Internet.
Yeah, we didn't know, Mark,
how good we had it.
We weren't quite as smart
as you were.
Lake:
What's your background, Joe?
I'm an engineer.
I've kind of been an adviser
to my mom over here.
The tech needed a lot of work
and needed something
that could really scale,
but the value in our company
isn't the technology.
The value is really
our providers.
90% of our providers are
stay‐at‐home moms
looking for a side hustle.
They are super passionate.
They're always sharing ideas.
I mean, I love this part.
I think, at Stitch Fix, some of
the magic of our business
is in the stylists,
which is a very similar model.
Right.
How much are you paying to
acquire on each side?
Okay, so, we are acquiring
a customer for about $22, $24.
But you also pay to acquire
on the provider side.
Is that right?
‐Right. They cost $115.
Their value to us is
really in the thousands.
I have some
who haven't even left.
What does your data tell you
the typical use case?
Is it a family traveling
in a hotel?
Our data shows that the biggest
segment are private residences.
‐Really?
‐These are mostly grandparents.
They really like the service
that we're providing.
A third of our business
is vacation rentals,
and that's up
from being 20‐something percent.
‐How long do they rent for?
‐It seems so logical to me
in the vacation rental space.
Yeah.
Really strategic.
I'm really surprised
because the scale issue ‐‐
to your point,
you got to be national.
I don't know
if you can get big
unless you have
a national brand,
like a hotel chain
supporting you.
The route you're going down
seems super risky to me.
It's a great idea. I wish it was
corporate‐oriented.
I'm out.
Thank you, Robert.
So, you are unbelievable to me.
I love this business.
Which, yes, you can tell,
and it's infectious.
But for me, I'm still
a little bit confused
about how all of this works.
At this moment, I just don't
think I understand it enough
to buy in,
and so I'm sorry, I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
Guys, you have
the exact same problem
as any ride‐sharing service.
You got to spend $100
per provider to acquire them,
then you have to go out
and you have to build your brand
so that people call you,
then you have all
this territory to cover.
It's not that ‐‐
‐We're doing it, Mark.
You're not, though.
To get to where you are doing
100,000 transactions a month,
where you're making
real money,
you're gonna
have to continue
to raise a lot of money
after that.
$5 million ‐‐
‐I think we're profitable
after $500,000 more,
and my ‐‐
You may be cash flow
break even,
but you're gonna have to deal
with that equilibrium
having enough providers, making
sure they make enough money,
spending enough on marketing to
generate enough transactions.
That's the challenge
for this business,
and those are
the reasons I'm out.
♪♪
Katrina,
I'm one of you, man.
I'm in San Francisco.
I'm a female founder.
Come on,
we need some support.
Uh...I have a couple challenges
with this.
Like, the marketplace works
when you're looking
at a huge market opportunity.
There's gonna be tons
of transactions,
and I can take a relatively
small percentage,
and the math works.
Here, you know, I think
the 24% is great today.
Once you start introducing
partnerships ‐‐
Well, we get
other stuff, yeah.
Once you start introducing more,
is it still gonna be 24%?
I don't know.
How big is the market?
I think it's just
too risky for me.
Unfortunately, I'm out.
Thank you.
Herjavec:
Fran, you got Kevin left,
and God knows he needs
a side hustle.
‐I know. Come on, Kevin.
‐Good luck with that.
Look, I am not like
any of your other investors.
I'm Mr. Wonderful,
and I'm way more valuable
than a random VC,
not that these
aren't wonderful people,
but they're not a Shark.
Right. Right.
Is there
an offer coming?
I'm just helping you
get over the hump.
Take a deep breath.
‐Get ready.
Want to roll the drums?
[ Imitates drum roll ]
I'll give you
the $500,000...
20%.
‐Ooh.
Cuban: Oh, is that all?
That's nothing for you.
I respect the fact that
you've raised money already,
but you are so far
from being worth $10 million.
How would
you make that deal?
Would you make it on
a convertible note?
Nope.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause if you made it on
a convertible note,
then that wouldn't
knock out all of my ‐‐
I know
exactly how that works.
Come on, that's fair.
Are you willing
to take 20% dilution?
What do you say, Fran?
No, I don't think so.
10%.
No.
10% with some other
sort of deal.
You're getting closer.
I can't do 20%.
You're still a startup.
You're still ‐‐
But I can't have it
wipe up all my notes.
Why is that my fault?
‐I get diluted to 30%.
‐But why is that my fault?
And you don't want me to be
diluted to 30%.
You decided to ask for $500,000,
and then you say to me,
"I'll give you half a million
dollars for 5%"?
That ‐‐
I'm not gonna do that.
I'm willing to talk about it,
but 20% ‐‐
‐And we are talking.
‐[ Chuckles ]
Get him, Fran!
Get him!
‐Greiner: Come on, get him!
‐Fran ‐‐ Fran ‐‐
Don't you ‐‐ Don't you want me?
Don't you want me?
Baby?
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
Fran, I have to feel loved.
I have to feel the love.
And the love is ‐‐
This is making me
uncomfortable.
[ Laughter ]
‐Come on, Kevin.
‐I'm taking inordinate risk.
I'm giving you
half a million bucks.
I'm giving you a solid
opportunity.
Come in
on a convertible note.
I don't have to do them.
That's the whole point.
I get what I want.
All right.
20%?
Can't do it.
Oh.
Cuban:
Way to stand your ground.
Good for you,
hold your ground, Fran.
Congratulations, guys.
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you.
‐Good luck to you guys.
‐Bye.
‐Fran.
I'm out.
‐Thank you.
‐See you guys.
Greiner: Bye.
♪♪
It's okay.
It's all right.
I tried.
I would have taken a deal
at a lower valuation,
but he was all the way
to $2.5 million,
and that was just too big
of a delta from our goal.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a healthier
version of a decadent treat.
[ Bell rings ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Frankie Yamsuan.
I'm seeking $180,000 for 18%
of my company, Coconut Girl.
[ Chuckles ]
I don't know about you, Sharks,
but I love summertime.
There is nothing better
than relaxing by the beach
with some creamy ice cream.
But let's be honest,
these sweet treats
don't really help the waistline,
especially during bikini season.
We all want to indulge
and treat ourselves
without compromising
our healthy lifestyles, right?
Well, that's why I created
Coconut Girl,
the best‐tasting, dairy‐free,
gluten‐free
nice‐cream sandwiches
that are out of this world.
Our guilt‐free sandwiches
are made with all‐natural,
good‐for‐you ingredients like
organic coconut milk,
honey, dates, and maple syrup.
So, Sharks, whether you're
bumming it on the beach
with our Beach Bum Maple...
[ Chuckles ]
...saying "Aloha"
to Aloha Chocolate...
Aloha.
...or want to hang 10
with our Hang Loose Vanilla,
Coconut Girl has any flavor
you're craving
to satisfy your sweet tooth,
and all without
any of the guilt.
Bring that over here.
Come on.
So, Sharks...
[ Laughter ]
...who's ready to take on
this sweet deal
and ride this wave
with Coconut Girl?
Me, me, me. Feed me.
Feed me.
‐Ready?
‐Pick us! Pick us!
Are you guys ready
for some ice cream?
‐I'm so happy about this.
‐Thank you.
No calories, right?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Thank you, Frankie.
You're welcome.
Mr. Wonderful.
Thank you, Frankie,
AKA Coconut Girl.
‐You're welcome.
‐Feed me.
Come on, Frankie, you should've
come down here first.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Greiner: I have chocolate.
‐Saved the best for last.
‐Thank you.
‐We have one of each, right?
‐Feed me.
Yamsuan: Yes. So, you have
all three flavors,
and they all have
the same cookie,
which is made
out of almond butter.
Herjavec: Oh, my God.
It's my version of
chocolate chip cookie.
‐This is amazing.
‐Thank you.
And there's a crunch
to the cookie,
which is pure cocoa nibs,
no added sugar.
O'Leary:
So, Frankie, this is no dairy?
No dairy,
made with coconut milk.
So, isn't the compromise
heavy‐duty calories?
‐Not more than ice cream.
‐With my products,
my main focus is
the good‐for‐you ingredients.
So, this is why I created it.
I was sick and tired
of the health food industry
lying about what's healthy,
the low fat, no fat, zero sugar,
but it was actually making me
sick and fat.
So, Frankie, you said
this is for the beach,
and when I put on my Speedo,
I got to look good.
[ Laughs ]
So, how many calories,
Frankie?
250, right?
The package
that Mark is holding.
‐250?
‐Yes.
So, this is actually rather
large for 250 calories,
but with healthy ingredients.
Yes. And the great thing
about my products, you know,
compared to the conventional
ice cream,
because of the nutritious
ingredients,
one sandwich will fill you up.
Frankie,
what are your sales?
Yes, so, this is year 3
for me being in retail.
Last year, I did $120,000.
The year before, I did $60,000.
So, this year, I'm on track
to do $300,000.
Good for you.
How are you selling it?
Sell them
in big‐box retail stores
just in Southern California
at the moment.
And you have a co‐packer
that does this?
Um, I did have a co‐packer that
was producing the baking parts.
Um, they got really busy,
so now I'm back to square one,
and I'm full‐on producing
everything on my own.
How are you gonna scale
this business
if you don't have
a co‐packer?
Well, the main goal is to
obviously scale it up to there.
But I've made my products
really efficient.
When I first started
the company,
we actually used to do them
by pints,
and I saw a bunch
of my customers
making them
into ice cream sandwiches.
I was like, "That's brilliant,"
so I switched over and just
focused on the sandwiches.
How did you get into this?
What made you ‐‐
I've always wanted to be
an entrepreneur.
You know, I was born
in the Philippines.
I came here when I was 5.
I saw my mother work two jobs
to give us an opportunity.
Um, you know, I struggled
specializing in one thing,
so I dropped out of UCLA,
but I was always passionate
about health and fitness.
I was always obsessed with
creating healthy alternatives
to everything that I loved,
the sweets that I missed.
And, you know, so I was just
doing it in my home kitchen,
and I realized there was
a business to it,
so thought of the name, and so
I created this icicle tricycle.
So, every weekend,
I would go to fitness events.
So, when a grocery store
approached me
and asked if I did
wholesale, I lied.
I said,
"Yeah, I do wholesale."
That's always
the right answer.
So I, you know,
went online,
and I figured out how to do
barcodes, nutrition labels.
I just learned on my own
and figured it out.
What stores are you in?
Whole Foods
is my biggest account.
How many locations?
Um, for Whole Foods, 30.
But we just got
the green light
to be in Hawaii, Nevada,
and Arizona.
And I just got picked up
by one of the biggest
natural food distributors
as of last week.
What do you sell it for, and
what does it cost you to make?
So, they retail for $4.99,
up to $5.49.
Is that expensive?
No, that's normal.
My biggest competitor, who
launched a dairy‐free product,
actually upped their price
to match mine at $5.49.
‐Oh, really?
‐Yes.
But you didn't say how much
it costs you to make.
Oh, it costs me about $1.
‐Just $1?
‐Just $1, yes.
‐Wow.
‐And it's you doing everything?
I'm doing everything.
I have part‐time help,
but that's why I'm here
asking for funding
because I need to get back
to what I'm good at,
which is the sales
and marketing,
and be the face of my brand.
You want to find somebody
to do logistics
and operations for you?
Yes.
How do you distribute this?
It's, like, a frozen product.
So, right now,
we were direct distributor
up until we got
picked up by UNFI.
So now, they pick up
from my facility,
and that's the reason why we're
now getting the green light
to be in Hawaii,
because they cover that region.
And how are you selling online?
Can you ship these?
I do not.
It's possible.
I have customers
all over New York ‐‐
But with the dry ice
and everything,
it just gets really expensive.
‐The dry ice
is just very costly right now,
and I don't have staff
to fulfill individual
orders.
So, we don't do direct
to consumers at the moment.
So, beyond hiring people, what
would you use the money for?
‐To lower my food costs.
‐Okay.
I'm confident that I can get it
down to 50 cents. So ‐‐
‐50 cents?
‐50 cents.
My packaging costs ‐‐
‐You know what, Frankie?
I'm hearing enough.
I love healthy foods, right?
It goes
really, really well.
I don't even want to hear what
these people have to say.
I'll give you the $180,000,
but I want 25%.
Oh, that's what
I was gonna offer.
But you got to tell me.
I don't even want to deal
with all these meatheads.
I like the deal, too.
I'm your customer.
Frankie, Frankie, you got to
decide right now.
If you want to listen to other
deals, I'm fine with that.
I want to respect Lori.
Okay, then I'm out.
Ohh!
[ Chuckles ]
I'll give you
one last chance, right?
You can take the chance to hear
what she's saying...
Oh, wow.
...or you can go
with Alyssa's Cookies ‐‐
Are you willing
to go down, though?
To what?
O'Leary: You know,
I'll help you, Frankie.
I'll do it for 20%.
And I'll squeeze Cuban's head
for you.
♪♪
Only because he's an idiot,
okay, I'll do 20%.
O'Leary: No!
‐Oh, yeah!
‐Wow.
‐Deal?
‐And he's getting up.
♪♪
‐Oh, my God!
‐Deal?
♪♪
‐It's a deal.
‐Done!
Whoo!
You're killing it.
You're absolutely killing it.
Do you want a ride?
[ Laughs ]
No, I'll let you
take that out.
I want to see
what else you have.
Nice try, Kev.
Thank ‐‐
You owe me a big thank‐you.
‐I saved you 5%.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Nice try, Lori.
‐Ah!
[ Laughs ]
He tried to kill me!
O'Leary: There she goes.
Bye, Frankie.
Greiner:
Well, Frankie, congrats!
‐Now give me my $5.
‐I had a great offer.
[ Laughter ]
Yamsuan: They loved it,
and I'm so excited
to make this
the next household brand.
I wanted Mark Cuban
to be my Shark, my partner,
and it's happening,
so I'm really excited.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next in the Tank is a product
with the goal of making kids
love their glasses.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks,
I'm Nathan Kondamuri.
And I'm Sophia Edelstein.
We're from
New York City,
and we're the co‐founders
of Pair Eyewear.
When I was a kid,
I hated wearing my glasses.
I mean, let's face it,
there's nothing fun,
fashionable, or exciting
about the entire process.
Not to mention parents have to
shell out a fortune
for something their kids
don't even want to wear.
That's why we decided
to innovate
the entire eyewear experience
and take it
to a whole new level.
Introducing Pair Eyewear,
the first‐ever continually
customizable glasses
where kids can...
All: Swap the top!
[ Laughter ]
Our patent‐pending
magnetic technology
allows kids to easily swap on
any of our ‐‐
‐Cool.
‐Very cool.
‐Wow.
‐Oh, wow.
Yeah, any
of our full range
of fun, hip,
and dynamic frame tops.
Designed to mold
to any personality,
we've created the perfect pair
of glasses for kids,
all for a fraction
of the price
of those
big‐box retailers.
And now, as the biggest
Dallas Mavericks fan,
you know John is gonna
swap on that blue top
to rep his team
for the big game.
Yeah, boy!
And after choosing
her favorite polka‐dot top,
you know Annie's ready to dance
in style for her ballet recital.
In less than a year
since launching,
we've started a glasses
revolution
where kids everywhere are saying
goodbye to their boring frames
and hello
to their parents.
We're raising $400,000
for 10% in our company.
So, Sharks, which one of you
wants to pair up with us and...
All: Swap the Top?!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐We've got some samples for you.
Cool. Good job, guys.
Thank you very much.
I like your glasses.
Thank you.
How do the glasses feel?
They're very comfortable,
and they're light.
Here you go.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Edelstein: Amazing job, guys.
You guys did so well.
See you guys later.
‐Good job, guys.
♪♪
So, what's your background,
guys?
How did you come up
with this?
The idea for Pair
came from my experience
of wearing glasses
as a kid.
You know, I remember going to
the optical store,
having to choose between
five really boring options
and leaving with
this horrible blue frame
that I hated wearing.
‐Aww.
‐Oh, you have no idea.
My lenses were that thick,
right?
‐It's a huge stigma.
‐It was horrible.
And I was the kid walking around
with the tape on the frame
because I would break them
all the time from sports.
That's a huge problem
with kids that we found out.
So we actually met
at Stanford University
where we were both
undergraduates,
and we went out
and we interviewed
over 500 families,
and you couldn't imagine
the number of stories we heard
about kids breaking
their glasses, losing them,
and from the parents'
perspective,
they just feel like
the bad guy.
They have to remind their kids
on a daily basis
to wear the pair
of glasses
that they simply
don't want to wear.
I love the fact it gives kids
a little bit of control.
‐Exactly.
‐Exactly, it's a daily choice.
‐Here's the big question.
‐Yeah?
How much is it?
It's $95 for the frames,
plus the lenses,
plus all of the add‐ons
that are doctor‐recommended
for kids.
So, that's anti‐glare coating
and scratch‐resistant coating.
Including anti‐glare?
‐Including.
What is each add‐on?
Each one
is sold for $24.95.
And what's your cost
on each add‐on?
$6.
‐Wow.
‐Yeah.
Kondamuri: So, huge margins
on the tops.
We have 70% margins on both
the bases and the tops.
‐And how do you sell them?
‐That's fabulous.
Where do I buy them?
Everything is sold directly
online right now,
which is something
really different
in the glasses space
for parents and kids
because before, parents had to
bring their kids
kicking and screaming
to the optical store.
But through Pair, it's so easy
that you can do it
sitting on the couch from
the comfort of your iPhone.
I understand in
the eyeglass industry,
there's one Italian company
that has 80% share.
In Market Square, there's a
dominant player with 80% share.
Innovation comes
from people like you.
‐Yeah.
‐And as soon as they prove it
in the market with, you know,
some critical mass,
a few million in sales,
they knock it off
and crush you
like a cockroach.
Why are you ever going to
get scale
in a market that has
an 80% share behemoth in it?
Something that's unique about
the eyewear industry
is that these behemoths don't
actually innovate at all.
I agree.
They wait for you to do it.
Then they acquire you,
hopefully.
And then they acquire ‐‐
Or they may not be interested
in the kids market.
Guys, how much money
have you raised?
Tell us
about your investors.
So, we began by bootstrapping
the business
while we were
in college.
We had to reach out
to some family and friends
to get
some prototypes made.
We raised $150,000.
Congrats. Then what?
We beta tested with
around 75 families
to get feedback
on how the product worked,
how the frames worked
for kids...
‐Great.
‐That's great.
...and that's when we began
to think about
how we would launch this brand,
how would we go to market.
Did you raise more money?
We raised $1 million
at that time...
‐Wow.
‐...at a $4 million valuation.
And then the million
you raised,
was it from big
equity firms or individuals?
It was from a couple
of venture capital firms.
You know, nobody's asked you
if you have any sales.
Yes, so we have $100,000 of
sales in the last eight months.
Cuban:
Okay, so, wait, wait, wait.
What were your sales
last month?
How many actual customers
did you have?
Last month was
$15,000 in sales.
15? One‐five?
‐Yes, $15,000.
‐That's horrible.
So, we basically used
the marketing spend
to acquire customers,
but we've only spent $50,000
on actual marketing spend
to acquire $100,000.
Well, how much money
do you have left?
I'm just nervous
about how much capital
you have left
in the bank.
We have $150,000
left in the bank.
That's something
to be nervous about.
What have you spent it on?
Kondamuri:
So, a third of that million was
spent on product development,
a third was operations,
and a third was legal,
FDA patents.
How much do you have in
inventory at cost right now?
$150,000.
Oh!
Kondamuri: So, we have a good
amount because we wanted
to build up the product,
but then once we had
the customer acquisition cost
where we wanted it,
to start scaling.
Herjavec:
Look, my overwhelming view,
and I hate to say it
because you're so positive,
I'm not sure I see it as
a standalone company.
I almost see it as a feature.
Just my gut feeling.
I'm sorry, I'm out.
♪♪
‐Thank you, Robert.
‐Thank you.
O'Leary: Guys, I'm gonna take
a stab at it, okay?
Your sales are $100,000,
which is really underwhelming,
I got to be honest with you.
I was expecting something
materially higher.
You have a behemoth competitor
that has consolidated
the worldwide market
in one company
for 80% in Italy.
I don't think your patent
is gonna protect you
if they decide
to pursue this.
So, the way I look at it is,
I see two cockroaches
with glasses on.
[ Laughter ]
That's what I'm worried about.
I hope they don't crush you.
Good luck to you. I'm out.
♪♪
Cuban:
Your problem is cash, right?
So, knowing
there's a possibility
that you wouldn't get
a deal here,
you must be out there
raising money already.
So, tell us about that.
Absolutely. So, we are raising
money right now
where we've had investors
interested,
and we're potentially raising
$3 million,
and we have about $1.5 committed
in verbal commitments.
And at what valuation?
That would be at roughly
a 9 pre‐money valuation.
And so here you are,
coming in at...
$4 million.
Cuban: Yeah, $4 million,
so someone's getting ready
to take a big haircut.
So, we talked to them, and they
are just as excited as we are.
I think the way we see it
is that we only get
this opportunity, you know,
once in a lifetime, and we see
the incredible value
of bringing a Shark
onto the team.
♪♪
Guys, look, you're in a cash
crunch, you're raising money,
as would be expected,
and you're in the Bay Area,
so I get that it's
available to you.
Entrepreneurs love
to work with Sharks.
VCs don't.
Right? They may have said,
"It's okay.
Let's see what kind of deal
you have to cut."
But when it all comes down
and the rubber hits the road,
that always
creates friction.
That's not a battle
I want to fight.
Congratulations on what
you've accomplished
on being so innovative,
but for those reasons, I'm out.
‐Thank you.
Okay, so, three Sharks are out.
You still have two Sharkettes.
Let's see what happens.
I love you guys.
I think you guys are
super smart,
you're really thoughtful,
you've got that grit,
and all of that is
super compelling.
At Stitch Fix,
we have a big kids business,
and so I know
this market well,
and I think Lori and I have
really complementary
platforms here.
Right. And I think
the two of us together
could really be great,
compelling Sharks for you.
Is there an offer
in the future?
So, here's our offer.
We feel that, you know,
it's very risky as far as you've
taken in a lot of money,
but you don't have
a lot of sales.
So, we think a fair offer
would be
we'll give
you the $400,000,
we'll do it for the 10%,
but we'd like to get
a royalty
until we get our money back,
and we're gonna do $2
for each pair of glasses,
and then the royalty will stop
after we're paid out.
We think that you will
accelerate so much more with us
that you won't mind
the $2 royalty.
Don't you wish I'd never taught
Lori about royalties?
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Lori and Katrina are
offering $400,000
with a royalty of $2
for each pair of glasses sold
until the initial investment
is paid back
for a 10% stake in Sophia and
Nathan's eyeglass company, Pair.
We think you guys will be
incredible partners.
We know a royalty is tough
as a cash‐strapped business,
and we want to invest
all of our cash
back into growing revenues,
growing customers,
so we all get that better,
bigger outcome.
See? They are smart.
Would you guys be willing
to do 10% for the 400K
and 2% advisory shares?
We want you guys on as advisers,
we want your guys's input.
Wow.
You know, not all money and not
all advisers are the same.
Yeah, I think there's ‐‐
We really want to make sure
that you guys have the time
and space
to not be penny‐wise,
pound‐foolish.
I built a business that's over
a billion in sales now.
I did it
with very little capital.
Like, you're talking about being
in a cash‐strapped environment?
I've been there.
So, you know, we think this is
a really fair offer.
We think we can really do a lot
to accelerate your business,
and we'd love
to work with you.
Um, we know that.
Unfortunately, we won't be able
to take any royalty deal
just because ‐‐
But the thing is we feel ‐‐
'Cause, you know,
you saw we talked a while ‐‐
Katrina, Lori,
they've said no to you
seven times
in different ways.
They're not gonna
give you royalties.
Kondamuri: We want to work
with you guys.
We just know a royalty
is so difficult.
Look, we respect the fact that
you're sticking to your guns.
We'd love to work
with you here,
but respect you
if you want to walk away.
♪♪
Can we do $1 royalty?
‐Oh!
‐Do $1 royalty?
‐Ooh.
‐What?!
And...if we do $1 royalty ‐‐
You just gave us this whole
speech about no royalty.
We don't want to walk away
without a deal.
from these two.
That's what
we came here for.
‐We know these two are gonna ‐‐
‐How about $1.50?
We'll meet you halfway.
♪♪
‐$1.50, we'll take the deal.
‐We'll take the deal.
‐Oh, my gosh.
‐$1.50, let's do the deal.
[ Applause ]
Thank you, guys.
‐I'm so excited.
‐Wow!
Thank you so much.
‐Wow.
‐Thank you so much.
♪♪
Edelstein: That could not
have gone better.
They're both incredible
entrepreneurs,
and we can't wait to grow
this business with them.
I'm feeling so lucky.
Mm‐hmm.
Welcome to the royalty.
[ Laughs ]
Welcome to royalty.